yeah I love you have fun be careful see
you tonight
you're good a great brother what do you
want to do Avery okay so it looks like
you guessed the Wi-Fi password hey Chloe
we got this right piece of cake let's go
to the playground yeah you can get all
the links let's ask for safety Chloe
twist is happening
okay that didn't work okay it's really
hey Bri what's next
Avery Avery Chloe this is what you're
made for leave me mush find the child
Avery Avery Chloe Chloe Avery Chloe what
what is this place
Chloe Avery Avery I'm coming down stay
there okay okay hold on hold on no you
have to tell me when we're playing
hide-and-seek cause if I don't know
you're here oh he found Avery come on
I think yeah I think we're down in the
park
you're ready to taste the famous
macaroni and cheese you me and Chloe
we're all gonna eat together can I see
her
I can't it's got to be just the right
amount though scoop it helps us measure
that
it's okay you'd be surprised actually
how often I do that now I know that
you're definitely my piece why can't
Chloe have macaroni and cheese because
macaroni is people food puppy food right
because it's made for people just like
puppy boots made for puppies science
Park last year for a minute but a
founder before dark Foley and a breather
wonder wonder - oh I don't know I don't
know what I do if I lost you I'm in
trouble